for the purposes of the sunshine app
this information is purely theoretical
in fact you'll really only need to
consider this later when you're adding
things like sensor or location listeners
until then the default components will
handle much of this behavior for you in
any case now that you understand the
lifecycle and the way that the system
handles exiting your app when it needs
its resources you should hopefully
understand why exit or quit buttons in
Android apps serve no practical purpose
at most you can call finish on an
activity and it will get torn down
instantly that's actually exactly what
happens when a user simply hits back
from within their activity if you're
still not convinced check out the video
in the instructor notes where I explain
my reasoning with a little more color